這裡是 AI 101，全網最幽默的 AI 新聞
日本聲優 Kenjiro Tsuda 打輸了 AI
仿聲官司：
9月30日，東京地方法院駁回他的請求
可是同一份判決裡，法院首次講明
人的聲音也可能受到保護
Tsuda 輸了官司，卻留下了首次司法判斷
法院到底怎麼說？
判決裡最關鍵的一句是：
人的聲音跟肖像一樣，是個人人格的象徵
所以只要聲音有吸引顧客的力量
它帶來的商業價值
就可能受到公眾形象權保護
那 Tsuda 的聲音有沒有這種吸客力？
他配過《咒術迴戰》的七海建人、
《遊戲王》的海馬瀨人
那副辨識度極高的低沉嗓音
撐起他的職業形象和商業價值
就是他的招牌
但 Tsuda 認為，有人盯上了這副嗓子
Tsuda 這邊指出
一個身分不明的 TikTok 帳號
從2024年7月到2025年9月
發了188支短片
旁白都是用生成式 AI 模仿他的聲音
這些片也不是發好玩的
Tsuda 主張
這個帳號拿他的名氣換流量和錢：
累積超過21萬名粉絲
每個月估計進帳50萬到75萬日圓
不過這些數字是原告方的主張
不是法院認定的
那聲音到底像不像？
兩邊講得完全相反
Tsuda 拿出音響分析，說兩者高度相似
TikTok 的營運公司否認侵權
說那只是第三方聲音訓練出來的普通男性聲音據報導
上傳者還說 AI 用的是朋友的聲音
可是還沒等法院回答像不像
帳號就先不見了
官司還在打
上傳者就在2026年5月把帳號刪除
那些影片也跟著消失
也因為影片消失，官司就這樣輸了
Tsuda 提出的是刪除影片的請求
被告是 TikTok 的營運公司
不是匿名上傳者
影片已經不在，平台沒有東西可以刪
所以法院駁回
換句話說，法院沒有回答聲音像不像
也沒有認定這188支片侵權
更沒有判平台賠償
法院承認的是，聲音原則上可以受到保護
Tsuda 先前也曾撲空
據多個報導，他聲請公開發文者資料
東京地院也下令提供
可是連線紀錄送到業者手上時
已經過了保存期限
先前程序沒能鎖定上傳者
這次則是刪除標的在判決前消失
同樣的難題，日本政府也在處理
法務省從今年4月到7月開了5次會議
8月公布報告：
聲音靠現有的公眾形象權和人格利益
就能受到保護
這是對現行法的解讀
不是新訂一部聲音權法
政府這樣解讀
那聲音的主人自己怎麼想？
日本俳優連合說，聲音是人格、尊嚴、
信用和職業人生的一部分
一項國內服務的調查裡，48名實演者
沒有任何一個人同意自己的聲音被拿去用
所以回到 Tsuda 身上
最矛盾的就在這裡：他贏了原則
卻沒有拿到實際救濟要不要上訴
也還沒有公開決定
證據會過期、帳號能刪除、
內容一下就消失，法律雖然開始追 AI
卻總是慢一步